Born and Raised on a ranch in Arizona
Sandra Deo Conor at first found an
outstanding law school performance
wasn't enough to overcome male Prejudice
in the legal profession and I assumed
everything would be perfect and it
wasn't I couldn't get a job
offer and I was shocked by that but it
was her experience as a Republican state
legislature and judge that led to
President Ronald Ragan to nominate OK
Conor to the highest court in the US OK
Conor spent 12 years on the Supreme
Court as the only female member she
dismissed those who said gender was
sometimes a factor on how she
interpreted the law I always say like a
woman judge in Minnesota used to say
that a wise old woman and a wise old man
will reach the same decision in 1992 OK
Conor was The crucial vote in
reaffirming the Court's Landmark
legalization of abortion though she
joined in upholding certain restrictions
in other cases she advanced protections
for young girls harassed in school
finding the schools liable significantly
she joined a narrow majority of justices
appointed by Republican presidents to
stop the vote recount in Florida which
gave George W bush the presidency in
2000 some critics claimed she showed her
bias by reportedly expressing
disappointment privately that his
Democratic Challenger Al Gore had won
the popular vote but a Conor later
defended the independence of the courts
against assaults on judges
with partisan attacks and political
pressure
mounting it's much more difficult to
achieve fair and impartial
judgments make sure to subscribe to our
channel to get the latest news from Al
jazer